[Music]
Prince Louis turns five
youngest son of Prince William and Kate
Middleton is celebrating the Milestone
birthday with some new pics Louie all
smiles as he sits in a wheelbarrow in
this photo alongside mom and in this
solo shot with the birthday boy cheesen
from ear to ear while portraits of The
Prince and Princess of Wales kiddos have
normally been snapped by Kate herself
this time the fan went with a different
photog Millie Pilkington who shared the
shots to her socials too thanking the
royal couple for entrusting her to
capture the special occasion
we are on the eve of a coronation the
most important and momentous occasion in
Charles's life the rear picks come just
weeks ahead of King Charles's coronation
set for May 6th we will see the Wales is
including their children where they can
and et's learning whether princely will
attend is still up in the air The Source
revealing to E.T his parents will make
the decision closer to the event noting
Louis didn't appear at the Queen's
funeral but did join other activities
during the Queen's Platinum Jubilee I
think we can absolutely expect to see
Prince George and Princess Charlotte she
behaved so impeccably and on the day of
the Queen's funeral who've shown that
they are absolutely able to behave
according to a situation even one as
formal as this meanwhile ET Source says
the couple's two older children will
have a high profile role at the event
with the eldest Prince George serving as
a page of Honor this is going to be a
very exciting event for Prince George
Who as we know is now going to have a
very role he's going to be one of King
Charles's four pages he will follow
Charles down the aisle in Westminster
Abbey and help handle his robes it's a
very key role and a big responsibility
for a little boy don't forget this is
all part of the training for Prince
George who will one day be king and who
will like Prince Charles when he was
that much younger just four watched his
mother crowned this will be Prince
George watching his grandfather crown
with his father looking onto knowing
that he will be next
also in attendance Prince Harry but he's
going solo now we have had confirmation
that Prince Harry will be attending the
coronation alone there's some relief
that he's actually going to his father's
coronation that hadn't been in question
certainly for the past few weeks some
surprise that Harry is going alone not
so much when you realize that it's his
son Archie's birthday the very same day
so Megan is in fact going to be staying
home in California to celebrate that
birthday which is perhaps quite
convenient given the tensions between
the two families right now I think most
people are optimistic that this
relationship will heal over time I just
don't believe that the coronation is
going to be the place for that to happen
foreign